I am 23 years old I'm Indian and this is
the first time I'm ever gonna go to
India and I'm doing it to bring my
grandfather's ashes
back
it's a little bit hard to process when I
left I was 10
I remember getting on the plane and
sitting in the middle of the Pan Am Jen
and I just remember not being able to go
to sleep because it was so exciting and
I kind of feel to say right now we've
made it it's just been really humbling
this was the life that I could have had
my grandparents wept all of this to come
to America
this is clarified butter and it's added
to the vowels of make it more savory and
delicious very good you got a have a
good after about a year of just speaking
English at the house all the time I
remember one day in my brain all my
dreams were in India and then one day
they turned into English it's just
something about being here and having
access to like slices that makes it
completely different we are going to see
the homes where
we need uh become grew up how are you
feeling
going back to your house I'm very
excited and I would have take a lot of
pictures so where's the house dad should
be at the end yes this is the balcony
where we used to stand by me and I and
watch everybody play soccer I just
remember walking walking with my
grandmother to get milk let go at 4:00
in the morning after we came back we
would meditate and pray and that was a
daily routine seven days a week what do
you think looking at this house about
what it's like to live in America I
don't think there's any way to compare
the two so on the roof upstairs we used
to get up there and we'd fly kites and
we would have contests with neighbors
you see who could use the string to cut
down a neighbour's kite and those were
called kite fight smaller kids played
cricket and this part of the park and in
the larger kids played cricket in this
part there used to be a bush and I
jumped in the bush one day and inside
the bush was a business and I started
screaming Marga Marga
which means I'm dying seeing everything
has made me just so much more thankful
and grateful for my grandfather and
everything that he did
there are so many things that happen in
the city that it's really overwhelming
or like my stimulus
yeah I think I know how like where I get
my hustle from because this city does
not stop tomorrow we are going to hurry
to our to the river Ganges to deposit my
grandfather's ashes into the river and I
think that's going to be like pretty
intense I am so thankful that I can be
here to honor my grandfather that way I
already feel like I'm changed after just
one day
you